and i want to read a passage
from one of his lectures which i think
is
one of the greatest things he ever wrote
and which has been
a very marvelous thing for me it was in
a lecture
delivered to a group of clergy in
switzerland
considerable number of years ago
and he writes as follows
people forget that even doctors have
moral scruples
and that certain patients confessions
are hard even for a doctor to swallow
yet the patient does not feel himself
accepted
unless the very worst in him is accepted
to
no one can bring this about by mere
words
it comes only through reflection and
through the doctor's attitude towards
himself and his own dark side
if the doctor wants to guide another or
even accompany him a step of the way
he must feel with that person's psyche
he never feels it when he passes
judgment
whether he puts his judgments into words
or keeps them to himself makes not the
slightest difference
to take the opposite position and to
agree with the patient off hand is also
of no use
feeling comes only through unprejudiced
objectivity
this sounds almost like a scientific
precept and it could be confused with a
purely intellectual
abstract attitude of mind but what i
mean is something quite different
it is a human quality a kind of deep
respect for the facts
for the man who suffers from them and
for the riddle of such a man's life
the truly religious person has this
attitude
he knows that god has brought all sorts
of strange and inconceivable things
to pass and seeks in the most curious
ways to enter a man's heart
he therefore senses in everything the
unseen presence of the divine will
this is what i mean by unprejudiced
objectivity
it is a moral achievement on the part of
the doctor
who ought not to let himself be repelled
by sickness and corruption
we cannot change anything unless we
accept it
condemnation does not liberate it
oppresses
uh i am the oppressor of the person i
condem
not his friend and fellow sufferer i do
not in the least mean to say that we
must never pass judgment
when we desire to help and improve but
if the doctor wishes to help a human
being he must be able to accept him as
he is
and he can do this in reality only when
he has already seen
and accepted himself as he is
perhaps this sounds very simple but
simple things are always the most
difficult
in actual life it requires the greatest
art to be simple
and so acceptance of oneself is the
essence of the moral problem
and the acid test of one's whole outlook
on life
that i feed the beggar that i forgive
and insult
that i love my enemy in the name of
christ all these are undoubtedly great
virtues
what i do unto the least of my brethren
that i do
unto christ but what if i should
discover that the least amongst them all
the poorest of all beggars the most
impudent of all offenders
yea the very fiend himself that these
are within me
and that i myself stand in need of the
arms of my own kindness
that i myself am the enemy who must be
loved what then
then as a rule the whole truth of
christianity is reversed
there is then no more talk of love and
long suffering
we say to the brother within us raqqa
and condemn and rage against ourselves
we hide him from the world we deny ever
having met this least among the lowly in
ourselves and had it been god himself
who drew near to us in this despicable
form
we should have denied him a thousand
times before a single [ __ ] had crowed
healing may be called jung says a
religious problem
in the sphere of social or national
relations
the state of suffering may be civil war
and this state
is to be cured by the christian virtue
of forgiveness
and love of one's enemies
that which we recommend with the
conviction of good christians as
applicable to external situations
we must also apply inwardly in the
treatment of neurosis
this is why modern man has heard enough
about guilt and sin
he is sorely beset by his own bad
conscience
and once rather to know how he is to
reconcile himself with his own nature
how he is to love the enemy in his own
heart
and call the wolf his brother
the modern man does not want to know in
what way he can imitate christ
but in what way he can live his own
individual life
however meager and uninteresting it may
be
it is because every form of imitation
seems to him
deadening and sterile that he rebels
against the force of tradition that
would hold him to well-trodden ways
all such roads for him lead in the wrong
direction
he may not know it but he behaves as if
his own individual life
or god's special will which must be
fulfilled at all costs
this is the source of his egoism
which is one of the most tangible evils
of the neurotic state
but the person who tells him he is too
egoistic
has already lost his confidence and
rightly so
for that person has driven him still
further into his neurosis
if i wish to effect a cure for my
patients
i am forced to acknowledge the deep
significance of their egoism
i should be blind indeed if i did not
recognize it as a true will of god
i must even help the patient to prevail
in his egoism
if he succeeds in this he estranges
himself from other people
he drives them away and they come to
themselves as they should
for they were seeking to rob him of his
sacred egoism
this must be left to him for it is his
strongest and healthiest power
it is as i have said a true will of god
which sometimes drives him into complete
isolation
however wretched this state may be it
also stands him in good stead
for in this way alone can he get to know
himself
and learn what an invaluable treasure is
the love of his fellow beings
it is moreover only in the state of
complete abandonment
and loneliness that we experience the
helpful powers
of our own natures
when one has several times seen this
development at work
one can no longer deny that what was
evil has turned to good
and that what seemed good has kept alive
the forces of evil
the archdemon of egoism leads us along
the royal road
to that in gathering which religious
experience demands
what we observe here is a fundamental
law of life
enantiodromia or conversion into the
opposite
and it is this that makes possible the
reunion of the warring halves of the
personality
and thereby brings the civil war to an
end
end of quote